sí efectivamente es el objetivo de esta
manifestación y lo dices bien estas
porque en realidad se calcula 200
manifestaciones a lo largo de toda
Francia ustedes pueden ver a mis
espaldas este puente lleno de personas
no se pensaba quizás que iba a haber
tantas personas en esta manifestación de
París Pero esto se extiende por varias
calles en el centro de París La idea es
llegar hasta la Plaza de la bastilla que
está a algunos kilómetros de aquí donde
yo me encuentro la manifestación
justamente reclamando por la situación
de inflación que hay en Francia pero
también en todo el mundo a raíz de la
guerra en Ucrania los sindicatos de
izquierda son los que convocan y también
los estudiantes consideran que las
medidas que el gobierno de Emmanuel
macron ha tomado para hacer frente a
esta crisis No son suficientes viven
aumentos de salario de acuerdo a la
inflación y aumento de las pensiones y
justamente esto ocurre en un momento en
que el gobierno está dispuesto a
presentar Ahora sí de manera definitiva
ese proyecto de reforma de la es tan
polémico que pretende hacer solo un
sistema universal y terminar con los 42
regímenes especiales que existen en
Francia y sobre todo el tema más
polémico aumentar la edad de jubilación
a los 65 años hablábamos justamente ayer
que el gobierno pretendía utilizar un
sistema muy Express muy rápido y aprobar
casi por decreto esta reforma pero
finalmente después de reunirse con sus
ministros y con sus aliados políticos
Emanuel macron ha decidido seguir el
camino tradicional es decir presentar un
proyecto de ley de aquí al invierno esto
es enero y febrero y comenzar ahora lo
que llama una concertación con los
sindicatos para intentar que ellos estén
de acuerdo con esta reforma recordemos
que el proyecto viene de antes del covid
los sindicatos manifestaban en esa época
de las calles pero luego todo se paró
con la pandemia el gobierno suspendió la
reforma pero ahora la quiere retomar
porque obviamente es necesario y es el
gobierno por un tema financiero el
sistema de jubilaciones francés no se
sustenta y por lo tanto Hay que
organizar la dice el gobierno pero los
sindicatos no están de acuerdo sobre
todo lo que no quieren es trabajar más
pero hoy se esbozó que este sistema
sería progresivo que se aumentaría todos
los años 4 meses hasta llegar a los 65
años Así que vamos a ver qué pasa con
esa concertación con los sindicatos pero
el presidente Manuel macrón advirtió y
que sí el presenta ese proyecto de ley y
tiene un voto de censura en la asamblea
nacional donde recordemos ya no tiene
mayoría disolvería la asamblea nacional
Y llamaría nuevamente a elecciones
legislativas Así que habrá que ver lo
que va a pasar en estas conversaciones
con los sindicatos Y cómo va a
reaccionar la oposición a